okay so yeah I'm just going to say it
CS2 kind of sucks man like it's not
going to suck forever and I know that
valve are probably cooking up something
big as we speak but right now the game
is in sort of a rough Place cheaters are
running rampant there is zero new
content and the game play still just
feels sort of suboptimal CS2 is
floundering and the question is how will
valve fix it and when
[Music]
all right so before we dive into all of
the reasons that no one cares about CS2
right now friendly reminder that you
should totally come play CS2 with us I'm
talking of course about the score
Esports is official face it clan click
the link in the description below to
join so you can Squad up with me your
friends and our community pug using a
real anti-che win points and spend them
in the face it shop so yeah it is
absolutely no secret that CS2 is in a
bit bit of a weird spot despite the
steam numbers still being relatively
great there's no question that a lot of
the Fanfare surrounding CS2 has subsided
in the months since its official release
now there are reasons for this the first
and probably foremost is the agonizing
lack of content for context the last
case not map not operation or major
content update just the last case came
out in February of 2023 to be fair valve
have spent the better part of the past
year trying to get CS2 into a spot where
it's actually playable so it's sort of
understandable that additions might have
fallen to the Wayside the issue is that
when they transitioned from go to CS2 in
the first place they took out a lot of
the that you could already do DM
retakes surfing KZ War Games Etc now
some of that is back mind you but even
Bob nowhere to be seene CS2 is starving
for content and what's worse because
it's valve we we have absolutely no idea
when we're going to get it now I'll be
honest the content thing doesn't
actually bother me that much when there
were no Community servers that was a
problem but now that I've got my retakes
back I'm sort of chilling what bothers
me and again I'm just speaking for me is
CS2 itself and what I mean by that is
just sort of the way the game feels I'll
be honest I haven't touched CS2 for
recreational reasons in upwards of like
2 months I came to the end of the last
esca season feeling really really burned
out and just realized that I wasn't
really having fun with the game so for
the first time in years I took a break
what I'm starting to pick up on is that
I'm not alone almost everyone I talk to
hasn't touched the game in either weeks
or months I'm talking super sweaty faet
Grinders and casuals everyone I talk to
says the same thing the game is just
wearing on them a friend of mine put it
really well he said that that right now
in its current state CS2 is probably
like 20% worse than CSG go the problem
is that when you've lived and breathed
Global Offensive for as long as our
community has that seemingly marginal
difference can feel like a casm that
just obliterates your enjoyment of the
game movement in particular has been
criticized into Oblivion and rightfully
so CS2 doesn't feel nearly as smooth
seamless and Polished as its predecessor
why is all of this like so Madness well
when you've played Counter Strike for as
long as some of us have it can be
insanely frustrating to be playing Cs
and feeling like you're not I get that
itch to play Counterstrike that one I've
had for like 20 years and then I play
CS2 and it just doesn't scratch it a lot
of this is subjective and I'm not
framing it as anything but that it could
be that I was already playing too much
Counterstrike to begin with and just
needed a break anyway but I don't know
it does feel like the game is to varying
degrees driving people away in all
fairness that was on some level expected
new counter strikes have always felt
like go was a disaster at launch
Source was a disaster in general and the
expectation was that CS2 would also be
in need of adjustment and it'll get it
it will CS2 will for sure at some point
feel great that like the content
staleness is a problem that valve can
and I believe will fix how long will it
take them I don't and I'll be honest
that's sort of why I stopped playing the
game but I'm confident that these are
problems that valve has solutions for
there is only one thing that valve
absolutely cannot get a pass for and
that is the cheater problem let's just
say it cards on the table what did valve
think was going to happen when they
rebuilt the physics engine overhauled
the matchmaking system and completely
revolutionized tick rate as we know it
without making any meaningful additions
to the anti-che what the did they think
was going to happen what island of
delusional Insanity are they living on
that they thought that any of this was
going to matter if they didn't solve the
cheater problem I know that I'm getting
worked up but like this is one of those
things that valve just cannot get a pass
for like it's just it's insane and I
just can't wrap my head around it I
don't know if valve just like don't
think that CS2 has a cheater issue or
they think it's not that bad or they
just know that you know it will clean up
their Ms like they always have like I
don't know but it's just lunacy that in
the year of Our Lord 2023 we are
releasing entirely overhauled Shooters
with hundred million Esports
infrastructures that don't have
functional anti-cheats now obviously we
are all just going to keep playing face
it like nothing happened but you can't
expect or say the same for new and
Casual players this isn't how you grow a
game or usher in the next generation of
Counter-Strike lovers and I don't know
what's coming all right like maybe
they're cooking up some crazy V live
that's going to blow us all away
but if history is any indication it
seems really unlikely I feel like after
a decade plus of us dealing with this
and just them trying earnestly to solve
every other major problem that CS:GO had
to just half-ass this one I just it's
unacceptable the point of all of this is
just to say that CS2 is definitely in
something of a dubious spot and the
community is rightfully deservedly
sitting around wondering what comes next
I don't have the answer to that the
major is basically around the corner and
I am imagine that valve are hard at work
to just make sure that the game is in a
great spot I also imagine that a major
content update of some sort I.E an
operation will at some point be here the
issue is that we've gone so long without
a major content update that there's a
lot riding on this next one like if this
operation isn't mindblowing it will piss
off and indeed put off the community in
a non-trivial way and just when you
thought things couldn't get any more
egregious after 2 weeks without a
Content update valve released yesterday
a patch for CS2 with one line that fixed
geometry on vertigo so for all four of
you who've had your games ruined by that
and not
cheaters good on you whatever's coming
just please make it awesome valve like
we know that you believe like we do in
the future counter- strike and you guys
want to make it great but we're tired
man like it's not just the Casual player
base who's losing interest I'm losing
interest it's getting to the point where
I just don't want to play CS2 until any
sort of meaningful change is made and
that's not like some ungrateful or
heretical way to feel it is fair that we
expect better and again I like most of
us believe that long term it will get
better but it's a give and take and
right now it feels like there's a lot of
concessions being given by the community
and not a lot for them to take hopefully
that'll
change the saddest thing I knew like
young people who were grinding csgo
before CS2 came out they were so ready
for it they were so excited for it and
then CS2 came out and it was just so bad
it just put them off and they're not
playing it anymore and like that's the
saddest thing that's the thing that
makes me the most like heartbroken